>> Ed:
>> Ed: EVERYONE IS WATCHING.
>> Sandra: NOT TO THE OTHER
ENDS OF PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
THE WHITE HOUSE TRADE ADVISOR
PETER NAVARRO JOINING US NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> NEVER HEARD THAT THE OTHER
END OF PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
THAT’S GOOD.
>> Sandra: HERE WE GO.
YOU’RE ON THE SCREEN NOW.
3.3 MILLION PEOPLE FILING FOR
THOSE JOBLESS CLAIMS.
THAT IS A NEW RECORD, PETER.
AS OUR ECONOMY HAS COME TO A
NEAR STANDSTILL.
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE
REACTION TO THAT THIS MORNING?
>> THIS IS TO BE TOTALLY
EXPECTED BECAUSE THE WHOLE
STRATEGY OF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TO GET SOCIAL DISTANCING SO WE
CAN COMBAT THE VIRUS.
WE PUT PUBLIC HEALTH ABOVE
ECONOMICS IN THE VERY SHORT RUN.
THIS IS NO SURPRISE.
THIS IS EXPECTED AND WE SHOULD
ACCEPT THE NEWS BECAUSE WE ARE
DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
COMBAT THE VIRUS, SANDRA.
>> Sandra: SEEMS THE MARKET --
>> WE JUST GOT $2 TRILLION
WORTH OF STIMULUS.
FOUR POINTS OF THE COMPASS.
TARGETED RELIEF PARTICULARLY
FOR THE LOW-INCOME WORKERS, A
BIG FISCAL STIMULUS ITSELF.
TARGETED INDUSTRY RELIEF AND WE
HAVE A LIQUIDITY PIECE TO IT
WHICH IS UNPRECEDENTED IN
HISTORY.
SO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
DOING EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY
CAN TO DEAL BOTH WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO BE LIKE THE
BRITISH, I GUESS, IN WORLD WAR
II, A STIFF UPPER LIP AND FIGHT
THIS VIRUS.
>> Sandra: SO LET’S DIG INTO
SOME OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
THE DOW SEEMS TO BE ACCEPTING
WHAT IT IS SEEING.
IT IS UP 731 POINTS RIGHT NOW.
BUT FIRST TO THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
AS WE SEE 3.3 MILLION PEOPLE IN
A WEEK FILING FOR JOBLESS
CLAIMS, YOU UNDERSTAND THE PAIN
THAT SO MANY AMERICANS ARE IN
RIGHT NOW.
>> NO BODY UNDERSTANDS THE PAIN
MORE THAN THIS WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
TRANSFORMED THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY INTO THE PARTY OF THE
WORKING CLASS.
I SPEND EVERY DAY TRYING TO
HELP AMERICANS WHO WORK WITH
THEIR HANDS.
WE ARE ATTUNED TO THEIR PLIGHT
AND WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO GET
THEM THAT CASH CUSHION AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
WE’LL TRY TO GET THEM THE LOAN
WINDOW OPEN FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND LOOK, IT IS
TRUMP TIME HERE AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE WE’LL DO THIS.
WHAT WE’VE BEEN WAITING FOR IS
CONGRESS TO DO THEIR THING AND
WE’RE STILL WAITING.
>> Sandra: RIGHT.
TO THAT POINT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE WILL BE A VOTE IN
THE HOUSE TOMORROW.
BUT THE SENATE SUPPORTED THIS,
$2 TRILLION.
AS FAR AS THE CHECKS ARE
CONCERNED, WE HEAR SUCH VARIED
ESTIMATES ABOUT WHEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WILL BE
GETTING THOSE CHECKS WILL
ACTUALLY GET THEM.
WE HAVE HEARD A WEEK, 15 DAYS,
THREE WEEKS.
WHEN WILL PEOPLE GET THOSE
CHECKS, PETER?
>> IT’S NOT MY LANE, SANDRA.
WE’LL KNOW THAT LATER IN THE
DAY.
HAVE SECRETARY MNUCHIN ON.
WHAT I’M TRYING TO DO, SANDRA,
IS TO MAKE SURE OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR THE PROTECTIVE GEAR
THAT OUR HEALTHCARE WORKERS
NEED, THE GLOVES, MASKS,
GOGGLES, VENTILATORS ARE MOVING
BRISKLY INTO PLACES LIKE NEW
YORK CITY AND NEW ORLEANS AND
DETROIT AND PLACES LIKE THAT.
THAT’S WHAT I’M CONSUMED WITH
24/7.
WORKING WITH FEMA, WORKING WITH
HHS.
WE’RE FULLY ENGAGING THAT
PROCESS.
AND WE’RE WORKING DOUBLE TIME.
WE HAVE PLANES IN THE AIR, WE
HAVE FedEx PLANES AND FEMA
PLANES, MILITARY PLANES, WE
HAVE THE FULL FORCE OF THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE THE FULL FORCE
OF PRIVATE ENTERPRISE AND
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE DOING HERE
AND THAT’S WHAT I’M FOCUSED ON.
WE’LL GET THE CHECKS TO THE
PEOPLE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT IS
ALREADY GETTING READY TO DO
THAT.
>> Sandra: ON THAT NOTE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE KEY
PARTS OF THE CARES ACT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THAT $2 TRILLION
RELIEF PACKAGE, $500 BILLION
FOR HARD-HIT INDUSTRIES OF
WHICH YOU’RE TALKING $377
BILLION FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
AID AND BACK TO YOUR POINT, THE
PRIORITY, THE MEDICAL SIDE OF
THINGS RIGHT NOW.
THOSE ON THE FRONT LINES IN OUR
HOSPITALS, $100 BILLION FOR
HOSPITALS.
HOW WILL THAT MONEY BE USED,
ACCOUNTED FOR AS, PETER, WE
REFERENCED THE "NEW YORK POST"
COVER THIS MORNING, A NURSE
COVERED IN GARBAGE BAGS BECAUSE
THEY’RE RUNNING OUT OF HOSPITAL
GOWNS.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THE DOLLARS
ARE SPENT APPROPRIATELY AND GET
INTO THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED THEM MOST.
>> THE DOLLARS DON’T MEAN
ANYTHING UNLESS THEY ARE
CONVERTED INTO THINGS LIKE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT,
AND THEY HAVE TO COVER THE
HOSPITALS TREMENDOUS SURGE NOW
PARTICULARLY IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY HAVE BILLS TO PAY, THINGS
TO BUY.
THAT’S HOW THAT MONEY WILL BE
USED.
>> Sandra: OKAY.
I WANT TO DIG A LITTLE FURTHER
INTO HOW SOME OF THE INDUSTRY
WILL BE AFFECTED.
REPORTING IN THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" THAT STEVE MUTSCHIN IS
COMING UP WITH SOME SORT OF
PLAN TO TAKE A STAKE IN U.S.
AIRLINES IN RETURN FOR GRANTS.
CAN YOU CONFIRM THAT THAT’S A
POSSIBILITY?
>> I CAN’T CONFIRM OR DENY THAT.
AGAIN, THIS IS NOT MY LANE.
THINGS ARE MOVING VERY RAPIDLY
IN SECRETARY MUTSCHIN’S LANE.
NOT UNPRECEDENTED TO HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT TAKE EQUITY SHARES
IN COMPANIES.
IT WAS DONE SOME YEARS AGO.
BUT LET’S SEE WHAT HAPPENS
THERE.
I SUGGEST THAT YOU HAVE
SECRETARY MUTSCHIN OR LARRY
KUDLOW ON.
>> Sandra: WE INVITE THEM ON
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> THEY’RE A LITTLE BUSY
NEGOTIATING THE BIGGEST PACKAGE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
FORGIVE THEM.
>> Sandra: UNDERSTOOD.
IT’S FINE.
WE’RE THANKFUL YOU ARE HERE.
>> I HAVE TO EMPHASIZE MY ROLE
IN THIS CRISIS IS TO HELP HHS
AND FEMA AND HOSPITALS AROUND
THE COUNTRY GET WHAT THEY NEED
AND WE’RE JUST GETTING THAT
DONE.
>> Sandra: SO ON THAT NOTE, HOW
WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THE
PROGRESS THAT YOU ARE MAKING ON
THAT FRONT AS SO BADLY YOU ARE
HEARING FROM THE NEW YORK
GOVERNOR, WE MIGHT HEAR FROM
HIM IN A LITTLE BIT.
HE HAS BEEN TAKING ON ABOUT
THIS TIME EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
SAY THAT THEY’RE NOT GETTING
THE VENTILATORS THAT THEY NEED.
SEND THEM HIS WAY.
SO WHAT UPDATE CAN YOU GIVE US
ON THAT, IF THAT IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY YOUR LANE THIS
MORNING?
>> JUST A DAY OR SO AGO WHEN HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT NOT GETTING
THE VENTILATORS HE NEEDED, THAT
MORNING FEMA HAD SENT 2,000
ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS.
THAT AFTERNOON THERE WERE 2,000
ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS SENT.
MY OFFICE PERSONALLY HAD
SHEPHERDED 400 VENTILATORS THE
DAY BEFORE.
AND THERE WILL BE MORE TO
FOLLOW.
WE’RE SENDING -- FEMA HAS AN
UPDATE NOW.
WE’RE SENDING HALF A MILLION
GLOVES, THOUSANDS -- HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FACEMASKS.
SANDRA, THESE ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS YOU ARE ASKING.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
WE’RE JAMMING THE CHANNEL AS
FAST AS WE CAN.
WE KNOW THAT NEW YORK IS NOT
ONLY A HOT SPOT, BUT THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM THERE IS
OVERBURDENED NOW BECAUSE OF
THIS SURGE.
WE’RE BASICALLY SENDING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP.
BUT WE’VE ALSO GOT AN EMERGING
PROBLEM IN NEW ORLEANS.
WE HAVE DETROIT, CHICAGO,
SEATTLE, CALIFORNIA, MY HOME
STATE.
LIKE I SAID, THERE ARE PLANES
IN THE AIR EVERYWHERE NOW AND
AS WE SPEAK WE’RE GEARING UP.
LET ME TELL YOU ANOTHER KIND OF
THING WHICH I THINK SHOULD BE
HEARTENING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHAT I’VE BEEN DOING IS WORKING
WITH PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO
REPURPOSE SOME OF THEIR
FACTORIES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF TEXTILE
ORGANIZATIONS, WHICH INCLUDES
COMPANIES LIKE HANES, FRUIT OF
THE LOOM, PARKDALE MILLS, AS WE
SPEAK THEY HAVE REPURPOSED SOME
OF THEIR GARMENT FACTORIES TO
MAKING MASKS.
THEY WILL START CHURNING OFF
THE ASSEMBLY LINE BY THE
MILLIONS PER WEEK.
HONEYWELL, WE WERE ABLE TO FAST
TRACK A NEW PLANT IN
SMITHFIELD, RHODE ISLAND FOR
THE THINGS THAT ARE GOLD, THE
N-95 MASKS.
THAT WILL BE RAMPING UP QUICKLY.
WE’VE HAD GENERAL DYNAMICS, I
CALLED THE CEO THERE OVER THE
WEEKEND.
GIVE US WHATEVER YOU HAVE IN
INVENTORY OF WHATEVER YOU HAVE
FOR EQUIPMENT.
SHE MOBILIZED THEIR TEAM AND
YESTERDAY WE DELIVERED 4500
TYVEK SUITS.
THEY’RE GOLD.
A COUPLE KIMBERLY CLARK
A-SERIES SUITS AND THIS IS WHAT
IS HAPPENING HERE.
I COULDN’T BE PROUDER OF
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
I COULDN’T BE PROUDER OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
ENTERPRISE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR BRINGING THAT EFFORT
TOGETHER BECAUSE EVERY TIME I
CALL SOMEBODY.
IF I CALL 1,000 PEOPLE TODAY,
999 OF THEM IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WILL BE MORE THAN
WILLING TO DO WHATEVER WE ASK.
WHATEVER WE ASK.
>> Sandra: I KNOW THAT THERE IS
A DELICATE BALANCE.
YOU ALREADY HEAR THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT WANTING TO REOPEN
ASPECTS OF THE ECONOMY WHILE
WE’RE STILL BATTLING ON THE
FRONT LINES THIS DISEASE.
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE STORY
GOING FORWARD.
LOVE TO CHECK BACK IN WITH YOU